hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my legends of tomorrow episode 6
video just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet if you have any
friends that haven't started watching
legends of tomorrow yet this is the
episode you need to show them especially
if they're big arrow fans they're
probably gonna eventually try to do the
same thing with flash characters so
we'll see like the tornado twins the
children of Barry and iris from the
comics
maybe we'll see Bart Allen this way and
as shitty as they found the place it did
seem like they left on a very hopeful
note like okay let's power all this
on we got some villains to take down so
let's do top 5 WTF and I'll explain
Easter eggs as we go along there were a
few minor changes from the comics but I
totally love the way they changed things
starting with number 5
Green Arrow no man's land if you're not
familiar with it no man's land is this
big Batman storyline where Gotham City
is destroyed and essentially walled off
from the rest of the United States
there's a state of emergency it turns to
complete chaos it's kind of like a
mixture of arrow season 1 and what they
did during Dark Knight Rises Bane taking
over the city and blowing up all the
bridges now in this case it's
Deathstroke in the case of the episode
Grant Wilson Deathstroke and in the
comic the disasters caused by an
earthquake so imagine a city rocked by
the undertaking if they were to wall it
off it's a really good example of
complete chaos
so Star City 2046 is kind of like the DC
Comics version of John Carpenter's
Escape from New York which is an awesome
movie opening connor hawke wTF is really
just a carryover from last week's
episode so we had already seen it it was
surprise surprise he doesn't know
about any legends so on a number 4 WTF
heatwave and Captain Cold
or in Disneyland for criminals they end
up at a bar that looks kind of like a
foundry and he waved goes total rope I
just I love how Captain Cold is off in
the corner falling asleep at the table
they did a really good job of building
tension between those two characters
Captain Cold is slowly on the path to
becoming a hero he way wants none of it
he has that Joker mantra just warning to
watch the world burn so with the way
they left things between the two of them
it seems like either Captain Cold is
gonna have to take heatwave out
permanently or heatwave is gonna have to
chill give me all your hot and cold puns
heatwave zero chill number 3 WTF connor
hawke takes them into the old arrow cave
the new arrow cave that is now the old
arrow cave because we're in the future
we see a bionic arm that looks like it's
modeled after Ray Palmer's technology
and out of this
Oh's walks old man queen put down the
bow John you're embarrassing yourself
speech number two WTF Connor is John
Diggle jr. this is so awesome it's a
change from the comics
Connor was all of her son in the comics
I love that they made him Diggle son and
they don't say anything about what
happened to diggle's daughter when
Oliver says they're gone it's meant to
be ambiguous you could read it either
way some of them are dead they're
probably dead but some of them also fled
the city went Deathstroke grant willson
entered with his army speaking of which
when Oliver tells them where to find the
tech that they need to fix the Waverider
he drops a Denny O'Neil Neil Adams
Easter egg always loved their shoutouts
it's a long-standing tradition to use
comic book creators names as street
signs so any time an arrow they say a
street name it's probably an easter egg
for a comic book creator and finally
number one WTF rebirth of the green
arrow although technically he passes the
mantle to Connor officially good
shooting there John
the names Connor whatever it is it's
also Green Arrow that's him officially
passing the mantle even though now
they're gonna exist in this Batman
Beyond situation like where Bruce Wayne
is a mentor but he's an old man he's not
quite as quick as Terry McGinnis so he
gives the mantle to him he's the one
that runs around in the suit so you guys
can write all the Batman Beyond arrow
beyond fanfic you want now I know a lot
of you were wondering about Grant Wilson
from the comics he has three children in
the comics there's Rose Wilson the first
Ravager there's Joseph Wilson which they
mentioned during arrow season two so we
know he exists on the show somewhere too
his name is Jericho in the comics he's a
different character that was part of
Teen Titans for a brief period then
there's this arc during the new 52 where
Grant Wilson
Slade's other son tries to kill him but
ends up becoming him so he becomes the
new Deathstroke let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the episode you know just the idea
that Felicity became the new Ray Palmer
Oliver Queen with one arm being this
grizzled old Bruce Wayne type character
mentor to Connor Hawke who is diggle's
son that was actually probably my
favorite part finding out that the new
Green Arrow was John diggle's son but
it'll be interesting to see how they
address this whenever they go back and
they see Oliver during present day
during 2016 will there be any jokes
about post-apocalyptic Star City 2046
there were some parallels between
this episode and when Barry and team
flash went to earth to Martin Stein had
that speech where he's like even though
this future isn't real it's real for
Sarah just you know Barry going to earth
to that was not his earth that wasn't
his reality but it was still real for
him so I know a lot of you were
wondering there is a new episode next
week there will be space pirates and it
will be awesome so even though arrow and
flash are on break for the next couple
of weeks there will be new legends of
tomorrow episodes every single week
which actually reminds me
congratulations to this week's DC
giveaway winner Edward Noel be sure to
private message be on the back end of my
channel so I get your contact details
there'll be all kinds of bonus videos
next week so I'll start a new round of
the giveaway next week my next DC video
will probably be a trailer video for the
next episode of flash because they have
their first female speedster on the show
it is gonna be bad freakin ass and just
address it I didn't want to talk about
it too much because I wasn't a big fan
of it but the subplot with Jax and Ray
Palmer competing for Hawkgirl it really
wasn't a competition and I felt like it
was a little unnecessary I think they
just wanted it to lighten the episode up
everything just felt so serious for most
of the episode they just wanted
something to balance that out just so
that the whole episode wouldn't be a
total bummer so I totally forgive him
for that and thank God that that's not
gonna continue to be a thing all said
and done this is my favorite episode of
legends of tomorrow just in general I
think I think everybody does want to see
legends of tomorrow interact with the
other arrow flash characters more even
though they want it to be its own show
we will still continue to see a lot of
things from arrow in the flash from
those different shows so if you really
like running the old Oliver Queen
running it to John Diggle jr. we'll see
stuff like that for the flash eventually
to the other really big news today was
the daredevil season 2 trailer if you
guys haven't seen that yet you can click
here it has a whole bunch of elektra in
it they confirmed who iron fist is gonna
be I talked all about it and you can
click here for all my favorite times
Batman killed someone in the comics just
because they're talking about the Batman
V Superman R rating thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight